you've been in 16 elections in the last
three decades and that time you've gone
from a staunch Republican to an
independent to a Democrat your own words
Charlie have come back to haunt you for
life I oppose amnesty for illegal
immigrants I support traditional
marriage and I have never supported a
new tax or big spending program I
support a constitutional amendment to
protect traditional marriage and I
oppose adoption by gay couples what I
understand though is that the party has
changed dramatically from what it was
when I was a Republican and what I've
seen is that it's so anti-minority
frankly this Governor is making it
harder for African Americans to vote in
my state uh and books pardon books just
so not true do you know how many Cubans
and Hondurans and all sorts of people I
meet here in Florida every day who
absolutely love Ron DeSantis and they
believe in borders and all of these
things so he's just he's just sort of
nothing